this is all that remains of an apartment
Block in the city of uman in central
Ukraine
the government says more than a hundred
people lived here many would have been
asleep on the explosion ripped through
their homes killing friends and
neighbors
distraught onlookers a man unable to
contain his shock and grief
I never thought this could happen says
this woman we are covered in blood the
rocket hit our building all the windows
have shattered children were sleeping
here it's good that they are alive but I
was so afraid Russia we hate you
this is one of what the Ukrainian
government says were 23 cruise missiles
and so-called Kamikaze drones that
Russia fired in the early hours of
Friday morning
some were reportedly launched from as
far away as the Caspian Sea
21 intercepted says the Ukrainian
military but Falling debris from
powerful exploding projectiles can kill
two
Emergency Services carried the dead in
body bags to waiting ambulances
Moscow has repeatedly said it doesn't
deliberately Target civilians but
thousands have been killed by Russian
missiles drones and shelling in densely
populated towns and cities since the War
Began my daughter is classmate lived on
the ninth floor of the destroyed
building I don't know how but praise God
they're alive it's a great tragedy
President Vladimir zielinski said on his
telegram Channel this Russian Terror
must face a response from Ukraine and
the world and it will
preliminary information is that 109
people lived in that section and 27 of
the 46 flats are completely destroyed we
organized operations as fast as possible
to rescue the people who are alive and
trapped under the rubble canine units
are also at the site
Ukrainian officials say other cities
here to include de nipro in the east
nikolaev in the South 11 missiles and
drones intercepted over the Kiev region
and explosions heard in portava and
kremenchuk on the donipro river
it's been almost two months since such a
widespread bombardment so why now the
attacks come ahead of an expected
Ukrainian counter-offensive one which
the head of NATO Yen stoltzenberg says
will involve nine brigades of Western
trained troops 230 tanks and 1 500 plus
armored vehicles also supplied by
Western allies and thousands of tons of
ammunition now whether in fact these
attacks were an attempt by Russia to
preempt that operation is difficult to
say but one thing it does show is
Russia's ability to strike targets
across this country whenever and
wherever it pleases John Stratford Al
Jazeera Kiev